monaci has logged over 15
000 hours on cs go yeah you heard that
right that's a lot of time in the server
but it gets even crazier when you
consider that he's literally 16 years
old that's over 10
of his entire life but let's put that
into perspective if monaci had played a
single competitive map of average
duration every day of his life he would
have about 3 800 hours in cs go he has
four times that now a thousand hours of
educational instruction a year is a
decent average for many countries
multiply that by 11 years of school and
he's still got more time in the server
than he's got in the classroom
ultimately though it looks like he'll
make a career out of this counter-strike
thing because he is absolutely schooling
kids in the server eight seconds if he
can drop the bomb it'd be everything but
it travels into the site one on two from
odyssey now sacrificial gives his
position
yeesh